i see my work as woven into the fabric
of cities
these soft fibers
move and adapt to wind and light and
rain and they are a way of being
they are about interconnectedness
i'm janet eckelman i'm an artist i bring
sculpture and
form and light into the public realm so
that we can
literally change the spaces that we live
in in cities
sculpture has traveled to five
continents
it takes an incredible team to create
one of these sculptures i am working
with computer scientists and artisans
and aeronautical and structural
engineers all over the world
[Music]
this part is hanging the way we want it
to hang on the diamond my studio is
where we incubate ideas
some of my newest work i'm using
data sets from science whether it's
human action or an earthquake and
tsunami
to reveal
our relationship with the world and then
i just start sketching whether it's with
a pen or a paintbrush
then we start to model it in three
dimensions in the computer and we also
make physical models
[Music]
they begin as raw fiber that is braided
into twine and rope
put onto bobbins and loomed using
machines and the ropes are spliced by
hand
to take the work and install it in the
city is a whole nother set of artistry
the piece comes together as a single
sewn garment for the city
my work is about the dynamic nature of
life
and it's always unfolding
during the day the colors of the
sculpture
change slightly as sunlight changes
at night i'm projecting colored light
that is very slowly gradually changing
it's never the same piece and you and
the person you come to see it with might
have completely different experiences
the work invites people to engage with
it
[Music]
you